we just had a great conversation
yesterday with David Roberts from Vox
about the irrelevance of facts in
deciding what is one's truth in the era
of Trump and David pointed out astutely
I think it's not that facts don't matter
it's that the definition of what
constitutes a fact has become completely
fluid in the minds of Trumpets who are
determined to defend Donald Trump no
matter what he does it's the circular
reasoning of if it sounds like a lie
we're being deceived that it's a lie the
lie is that Trump is a liar so to speak
Donald Trump is now straight up saying
it doesn't matter if he lies to his
followers and to the country as long as
he come up can come up with some defense
of why he lied so there's a few ways
that people in the public eye can handle
being accused of saying something untrue
you can deny that you said something
untrue you can deny that what you said
was untrue claiming it was actually the
truth and you can also say I lied but it
doesn't matter that I lied and that's
what Donald Trump is doing about the
justification for assassinating Iranian
general Kassim soleimani
without congressional authorization so
the first justification was Kassim
soleimani had to be taken out he was an
imminent threat to the u.s. planning
attacks eventually mentioned planning
attacks on multiple US embassies around
the world while Donald Trump was still
repeating that justification his own
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo started
using a different justification which
was we took out soleimani
because of his history of doing bad
things now taking him out because things
of things he did in the past is very
different than saying he was imminently
planning an attack on the United States
or its assets of course this immediately
became a topic of discussion because
first Donald Trump doesn't get
congressional authorization for the
assassination which he said under Barack
Obama presidents need to do then he says
the justification was imminent danger
then they change and say well it was the
stuff that he did in the past but then
done Donald Trump actually tweets you
know it really doesn't
or what explanation I gave it doesn't
matter whether it's true or it isn't
tweeting a day and a half ago the fake
news media and their Democrat partners
are working hard to determine whether or
not the future attack by terrorists
soleimani was imminent or not and was my
team in agreement the answers to both is
a strong yes but it doesn't really
matter because of his horrible past it
actually does matter here is Donald
Trump talking to Laura Ingraham a few
days ago asked by Laura Ingraham don't
Americans deserve to know why you really
assassinated him without congressional
authorization that's my wording not hers
Donald Trump said no they don't don't
the American people have a right to know
what specifically was targeted without
revealing methods and sources well I
don't think so but we will tell you that
probably it was going to be the embassy
in Baghdad you saw that happening you
saw up with all of the men very few
women circling it and circling it very
strongly and very viciously Trump says
no they don't have a right to know but
I'll feed you a lie anyway first the
strike was unauthorized by Congress
that's problematic then the Trump
administration gives conflicting
justification for why the strike
happened that matters Trump risk war if
he's risking war to prevent actual
imminent harm to the United States
that's very different than simply
choosing a politically convenient time
to assassinate a bad guy without the
authorization he claimed he needed now
it just so happens that the imminent
threat explanation is bogus multiple
officials from the Pentagon have said
there was no evidence of an imminent
threat there was no evidence that
embassies were about to be targeted
there's no evidence of any of it so when
a trumpet says that's right throw
credibility in the trash whatever Trump
says was the reason he assassinated
soleimani doesn't matter even if it's a
lie because Soleimani was a bad guy what
trumpets are saying is it's fine that
the president lies not for national
security reasons not because of
sensitive classified information it's
fine that he lies just for the hell of
it and for a political movement that
claims to hate post-modernism most of
them don't even know the term but those
that do claim to hate it they are very
comfortable playing fast and loose with
the definition of reality and
fact and empiricism and just calling
things what they are and Trump is right
in a sense it doesn't matter to his
followers if he lies who tells the truth
they don't care they will find a way to
support him no matter what they will
find ways to excuse his lies or simply
to claim that they are not lies which is
why we've got to go around them in
removing Donald Trump by voting in
November of 2020